[Music]
the polls heading into the Iowa
Republican caucuses look like well Trump
winning but what's interesting is what's
happening down here so we asked our
political editor you can write Aaron
zitner wonk if you want to explain
what's really happening in the first
stop of the Republican primary well the
race in Iowa is largely about who comes
in second and by how much it's going to
give us the first clues in actual votes
not in polls or in media attention to
whether the Republican Party really is
ready to consolidate behind Donald Trump
here's why the Iowa caucus will likely
determine how the rest of the Republican
primary will
go let's look at some of the scenarios
that could come out of Iowa first and
most
likely Donald Trump dominates that would
give us a lot of signals about where the
Republican party is right now because
the party in Iowa hasn't gathered behind
Trump Ronda santis has gotten the
endorsement of Iowa's very popular
Republican governor and arguably the
biggest Evangelical leader in the state
and he's visited all 99 counties Nikki
Haley meanwhile has been campaigning
hard in Iowa and is set up to spend the
most in ads leading up to the
caucus if Donald Trump runs away with
the race in Iowa that will tell us that
even influential Republicans don't have
the juice to persuade Republican voters
that it's time to turn the page and to
move on to another leader a second
possibility
Donald Trump wins but by less of a
margin and the second place is kind of a
tie between Ronda Santos and Nikki Haley
that's also a good outcome for Donald
Trump because it will mean that voters
who don't want him haven't Consolidated
around any individual uh Contender
against him and instead are dividing
their vote among multiple candidates
that happened in 2016 Ted Cruz and Marco
Rubio split the non-trump vote in a
bunch of States but that just allowed
Trump to win and rack up the delegate
count needed for the nomination and then
we come to a third scenario and that's
the one where a single candidate emerges
from Iowa with enough momentum to give
Donald Trump a real race throughout the
primaries if one candidate does well in
Iowa it would signal to voters in other
states and donors that they're a viable
Contender just like it did for Trump in
2016 or Romney in 2012 they both came in
second in Iowa but won New Hampshire
next next and eventually the
nomination and that's not unusual
whoever wins Iowa usually doesn't become
the
nominee it doesn't help that Iowa is
very Agricultural and very rural but
there are some places that could give us
Clues to what might be coming next in
the primary process and we'll look for
those here and here right around De
Moine and in the two University towns
just north of De Moine and over here at
the University of Iowa they're upper
income they are more highly educated and
that means they look a little bit more
like the state of New Hampshire which
votes next if Nikki Haley and Ronda
santis don't do well in these areas that
are suburban and University heavy it's a
signal that they might not be doing well
in the states that come next and there's
another reason Haley or disantis might
want to stay in the race the numerous
legal battles Trump is currently facing
they don't want to have dropped out if
something unexpected happens and all of
a sudden Donald Trump isn't there to
claim the nomination
Iowa hasn't been a king maker instead
it's been a win defining who the top
candidates are going to be in the
primary from a large field and boosting
the profile of those that do well in
2024 it will do it again but whether it
winnows it to one two or three
candidates will also show us if this
primary will be over in 1 month or
[Music]
six